i got sworn in on a monday raised my
right hand took my oath filled out my
paperwork
four days later i was taken hostage and
shot
a very difficult way to start your
career that hole right there
is where the bullet went in my back
that's the real shirt that you've kept
that's that's what's crazy about it
what got you to decide to become an atf
agent dealing with drug kingpins and
going to mansions and negotiating for
tons of cocaine
and stripper models bringing them
martinis and i was like man
you know what i can do that i can do
that
hollywood's version of undercover one is
a hoax
i still loved it man i love it every day
of it
your in hell's angels their purpose
is narcotics killing crime money
women anything to break the law the
mission was
to uncover violent crime did you ever
feel like those guys got so close to you
where you started liking them and then
you felt like you betrayed them did you
ever feel like that or not at all
i felt like that all the time the good
people
are not always all that good and the bad
oftentimes are not always all that bad
crazy craziest
you've seen ever on work we're working a
cartel case
one of the people we're dealing with got
sealed up in
a 55 gallon steel drum
and left out in the desert this human
being had become
like soup in that barrel how do you keep
yourself calm
but i felt like i could get to anything
bulletproof
what you say or what you did or how you
acted or responded
could be the factor on whether you lived
or not
[Music]
my guest today is jay dobbins he's a new
york times bestseller 27 year old
federal agent
retired federal agent as an atf
again alcohol tobacco firearms i don't
know why they
still have the alcohol and tobacco
obviously they did back in the days in
72.
but uh he's got one of the most unique
stories a very very unique story of what
he did
going undercover i think on 500
different cases and one big one being
the one that he did with
uh the hell's hell's angels which for 55
years nobody could infiltrate
until jay dobbins showed up and then he
was able to infiltrate in two years so
jay thank you so much for being a guest
on vacation thank you for having me and
welcome to your audience
yes so you know for me a fun fact is one
of my
very very good friends was a mongol
and he was a mongol who decided to
change his life and he was at a locker
center valley
and he had a crazy life in the past all
the tattoos the stories to go with it
biker everything but he had become a
peacemaker he was kind of trying to get
guys
to leave the life rather than uh but
still the mongols liked him they were
still good with them
and we traveled together for a good five
six years and he would always tell me
stories about the mongols and
the the fights the battles between the
two so i always had to hear stories from
this guy when he was a mongol out of
crescendo valley but
what what got you to decide to become an
atf agent you were an athlete before how
do you go from that to being an atf
agent
you become an atf agent from an athletic
background by being a failed athlete
to be quite honest with you i never had
a plan b i was going to play
professional football
and um everything that i did focused
around that
when the time came i just i wasn't good
enough
i don't have excuses there's a lot of
athletes out there that like
oh if i only wouldn't hurt my knee or i
hurt my back or the coach didn't like
you
i have zero excuses i did
every single thing within my power
to play professional football i just
wasn't
good enough um and so i have a clear
conscience about that
very interesting most most people that
that's a very interesting perspective
you just gave because
you know you have friends who say if it
wasn't for this knee injury if it wasn't
for this back injury if it wasn't for
this ankle
i may have made it there you're just
saying you didn't make it there but the
one story i like that you said
when you had a running where was it at
when you experienced uh training with
andre reed and
jerry rice well that was in the process
i was still on my original plan a
and i went to the 1985 nfl
comma which is for lack of better terms
or for your
audience out there that's not football
fans it's the nfl's meat market
it is where prospective players come in
and you're weighed and measured and
tested
in the presence of coaches and general
managers and owners
and they decide whether you are worthy
of being a part of their
organization so i was an all-pac-10
football player in college i had a very
very good
college football career so i went to the
combine
thinking this is my chance i'm going to
show off
right so i get paired up with a couple
guys i've never heard of before
one dude was from kutztown state i
hadn't even heard of it i asked him
where's it at you know
shake hands my school's in pennsylvania
and i'm shaking hands with them
in my internal dialogue is that i'm
going to whip your ass today
right another dude from this little
school in in mississippi that i never
heard
well we start working out and my my ego
and my self-confidence was very high
and in 10 minutes i realized i was not
going to be a professional football
player
because these these kids that were my
size my build
i'd never heard of before i couldn't
keep up with them
they were they were everything about
them as football players
was better than me well the kid from
kutztown state was andre reed
who played 15 years in the late and is
in the hall of fame
and the guy from the little school of
mississippi went to mississippi valley
state it was jerry rights
arguably the greatest football player to
ever wear
a helmet and shoulder pads so i was not
judging myself against the fairest
competition
but nonetheless those guys were absolute
freak show athletes and uh man i was
just
i was a common man and let me let me
tell you i'm
i was a bills fan when i came to the
states most people don't know i was a
die-hard buffalo bills fan
bb kelly bryce pop
bruce smith you know uh all those
players
obviously andre reed thurman thomas they
just had a stacked squad those four
years
and uh to be able to say that you
watched andre reid
in 1985 and jerry rice
at that point did you kind of tell
yourself these guys got to kill it in
the nfl
were you out of were you seeing the
major separation of talent between them
and others
it was obvious like no one knew who they
were yet
i mean they had good college careers
great college careers actually
but but they were not on a national
stage yet
kutztown state and mississippi valley
state had not put them on a national
stage
um who they were going to become was
still yet to be seen
but even as one of their peers working
out with them
you you could look at these guys and say
i'm like man they're different man these
cats are different
that's it that's the part right there
that's the part right there when you
tell the difference
between talent and you get to levels i
asked kobe one time kobe
who did you face off where you kind of
knew like this guy's at a different
league because
he was ranked the 56th best player in
high school
and he was coming up and he was sizing
everybody up and he's like man some of
the guys you faced up
you knew they were superior and you knew
they were going to do something and then
obviously kobe ends up becoming delayed
kobe bryant
god bless us all he ends up becoming who
he is today so so you're an athlete
you're playing football
plan a i'm going to go in the nfl i'm
going to be a star that's going to be my
career and i'm going to do whatever i'm
going to do later on maybe coach maybe
stay in the game
i don't know what it'll be but i love
football at what point do you say
i'm going to go be an atf agent i
i wasn't drafted in the nfl i went and
played a partial season in the canadian
football league
i played a partial season in the united
states football league when you play
canadian football it was flutie playing
at that time or who were the stars in
cfl
well um i played with the ottawa rough
riders
and probably the biggest name on our
team like
actually didn't make his big name as an
athlete
our quarterback was a guy named jc watts
who ultimately became a congressman from
oklahoma
jc watts jc watch was the quarterback
[Music]
a truly amazing man he's a man that's uh
that's very important in society right
now 100 as a black man as an athlete as
a politician
um he's got an important voice
so you're playing for cfl jc watts is
your quarterback
and then uh you tried a couple other
things there and then and then what are
the transition come to each you know i
get i get cut into
the cfl i wasn't good enough to stick
there i i played uh a partial season in
usfl when that league folded
i actually had a tryout with the chicago
bears
and i went to a camp
with the bears and the coach was mike
ditka at the time
and and coach ditka when he was letting
me go when he was releasing me
kind of put his arm over my shoulder on
the field and he said kitty goes i love
your attitude but you're 20 years too
late for this league
20 years how old were you at that time i
was 24.
you know but so meaning five you would
have been a star
yeah my style of play just did not the
athleticism
had had grown and it was you know i say
this all the time
if you take the worst nfl team
out there i don't care who you decide
that is and then you
go to their practice squad which are the
guys that are not on their active roster
and find the worst player on the
practice squad
of the worst nfl team that kid
is an amazing football player that kid
is a freak show football player
that's how hard it is to
survive and stick in the game at that
level
that's perspective that's definitely
perspective when you put it that way too
to to think about that so by the way
we've had mike did gone before i think i
was
with him at uh his restaurant in chicago
we met up we spent a few hours together
myself himself and his wife and
his interviews on valuetainment one of
my favorite guys you know this a guy
that
changed the game as a tight end and then
changes the game as an assistant and
then changes the game as a coach
and you had one of the best i don't know
if you watched the 3430 with him and uh
uh uh the whole story of the bears i
think it's 84.85 bears document one of
the best documentaries i've watched
i rented out uh um the entire hotel um
in new york i don't remember what the
hotel was called the ohika castle
in new york we had 32 rooms i brought
everybody and all the executives and we
sat there and we watched the
34 30 because there are so many great
lessons in that documentary
with mike ditka so now football doesn't
work out
you leave football where does atf come
in
well you know i was a young man and i
was lost i never had
a plan b um i was like whatever it is i
was doing
i was very good at being focused on it
and and
diligent and committed to whatever that
was
and for the first time in my life i
didn't i didn't have a plan a
um i knew as much of what i didn't want
to do
as what i did want to do i i never
chased
uh my money was never very important to
me
or my family i grew up in a blue collar
family my dad was a carpenter my dad
pounded nails for
a living my mom was a house cleaner my
mom scrubbed people's toilets for a
living that didn't want to scrub their
own toilets
right so we never had a lot but we
always had
enough um i knew that
i wasn't interested in chasing money
i wanted something so that
when my alarm clock went off in the
morning and i put my feet on the ground
i felt good i felt excited about
whatever it is i was gonna go do to go
through
and i wanted i wanted to serve i wanted
to serve others
um and so it's it's uh it's almost
hokey to tell this story how it came
about but at the time
this is mid 80s the television show
miami vice was very popular not that not
the movie not what like the younger
generation is not not
colin farrell and jamie johnson is who
you were talking about
the old the old tv show right
and i saw sonny crockett like
rolling around south beach in a
lamborghini with a hugo boss suit on
and dealing with drug kingpins and going
to mansions and dealing for
negotiating for tons of cocaine and
stripper models bringing them martinis
and i was like man you know what i can
do that
i can do that um
and and it grabbed me it grabbed like
hollywood grabbing
but what i didn't realize at the time is
that hollywood's version of undercover
work
is a hoax it's counterfeit right once i
was in it
i realized that that hugo boss suit that
sonny crockett wore
was a pair of cut-off camos and a
wife-beater t-shirt and flip-flops
you know that lamborghini was an old
beater
car the the mansions were
you know were trailer parks and i was i
was rolling up to single lines that were
on tilt with aluminum awnings hanging
off of them and
and rusted swing sets and cars on blocks
and the the k-pin
and the tv show was some guy sitting at
a corner bar with his
plumber's crack hanging out who didn't
have two nickels to rub together
you know the big massive dope loads that
we saw on television
it was an eight ball of coke that was so
step down with baby laxatives you [ __ ]
before you get high off
to be quite honest with you know the
supermodels that were
smoking and joking were sunny and
sitting on his lap
they were like straight skanks with
three teeth in their head
and tits like sweat socks with toes in
them with rocks in the toes
you know it was anything other than what
hollywood
had led me to believe it was and when i
saw the reality of it and
realized that the entertainment industry
had lied to me
i still loved it man i loved it every
day of it
i loved every day of it wow the fact
that you still loved every day of it
that says a lot about the world because
you know gary nesner he's the
uh fbi negotiator from uh what do you
call it uh david koresh with what
happened in
1993 at waco he got recruited based on
watching the mickey mouse club and he
saw j
edgar hoover on the show and he said
that's how he decided to become an fbi
agent because that inspired him
by the way this is twice now in one week
that says these recruiting stories of
how brilliant it is
to use a tv show two tv shows to recruit
people to the world
brilliant marketing if you really don't
look at just in a different world
look at what back in the day what 25
years ago
look what top gun did for the military
yeah look what top gun did for naval
aviation
for for military 80 years man
it was like the entertainment business
and hollywood is super powerful
yes very true by the way i don't know if
you know what hitler did hitler did uh
the first titanic
if you knew the story of the first
titanic he made the first titanic and
the director was one of his guys
and the story was making the the
the nazis uh the soldier the hero
so people around the world are started
saying oh my gosh what great people
these guys are so
you can also use movies to push a lot of
propagandas if you wanted to
that's used a lot i mean you know this
you're in the world so so now you go and
want to become an
atf agent you see the miami vice you
know you're
kind of wanting to have that don johnson
type of life you know going out there
having a good time
career starts how was your first week as
an agent
oh my goodness i got sworn in on a
monday
raised my right hand took my oath filled
out my paperwork
four days later i was taken hostage
and shot i i was shot in the back during
an arrest situation
the bullet uh went in my back in between
my shoulder blade and my spine
it passed through my lung it narrowly
missed my heart
and it exited my chest so
four days on the job and i was
laying in the in the dirt and
garbage and dog [ __ ] of this trailer
park
with blood coming out of my chest like
you're holding your thumb over the end
of a garden house
and i remember what days into it
four days i got i got hired on a monday
and i got taken hostage and shot on
thursday
i i remember laying there and a pool of
blood was growing around me
and an old worn out potato chip bag
like in the breeze blew through and
stuck in the blood
and then blew blew past me
and i was like oh my god i'm going to
die
after four days on this job in a in a
trailer park i'm bleeding to death you
know like
four days on the job i hadn't gotten a
paycheck yet
that was like that i count them now that
was a free test drive
and actually like knowing that question
was coming
have this ready for you so this this
this
shirt this is the shirt i was wearing
that was shot that hole right there
is where the bullet went in my back
and this hole right here is where it
is where it came out of my chest
so you know freaking believable
like like a very uh a very
obviously a very difficult way to start
your career
now now let me ask you what i read
somewhere is the fact that you had the
option to get retirement disability for
the rest of your life your life and you
still turned it down
well you know like it goes back to what
we said earlier like you know i'm from a
blue collar
family with me like my folks never
chased money i'd never chase money
i had attorneys lining up at the
hospital
come in and say hey kid you know what a
million dollars looks like you want a
billion dollars
about five million dollars you'll never
have to work
another day in your life let me take
this case
the government has put you in a
situation where they've created a huge
amount of liability for themselves
you are not yet prepared for this you
weren't trained for this
they want you and your story
to go away you tell me how much money
you want
and i'll get them to put as many zeros
on that check as you asked for it and
it'll never see a courtroom
and my response was to like just to get
out
i did not take the job
for the money i what i wanted truly
wanted
was a chance i wanted to get healthy and
a chance to come back
and see if i could do it right see if i
can do it without
messing up now jay let me ask you in
that moment
did your mom or dad talk to you were you
like that should i take the money what
this is what they're telling me
or was it just you made the decision no
i want to get back to my job
it was it was my decision my parents
were around me at the time
i think um i think now what uh
something years after that event man
should i have taken the million dollars
you know i don't know but um but i'll
tell you what everything in between
like declining that money and today i
would i wouldn't change a dang thing i
wouldn't change one thing
so it was the right decision and so you
said 30 some how many years ago was it
the day you got shot with that shirt
i was shot on november 19th of 1987.
november 19 1987. why and you kept the
shirt from
33 years ago something like that have
you ever washed that shirt or no
i haven't i use it as it's just a
problem it's just a product i use
by drinking but it's the real shirt
oh yeah that's it that's the real shirt
that you've kept that's that's what's
crazy about it
the uh the detectives so the detectives
in the case when i got to the emergency
room
the medical staff cut the shirt off me
and so they the detectives gave it back
to me
but it was all shredded up and my
mother-in-law
sewed it all back together for me to
make it a shirt again
oh so you were married at that time you
were already married
yes okay because i know you married two
kids i read that
uh with the family that you were okay so
now that happens
you come back you recover you say no i
want more i want more of this
so from there on you go become the atf
agent and you you were on 500 different
cases is that is that what is that
pretty accurate
i i was a i was an active participant in
over 500 undercover operations
sometimes on the point as the operatives
sometimes
as a team leader sometimes as a cover
agent but
but i was directly involved you know i
had fingerprints on over 500 undercover
operations
and out of those 500 operations that you
were working on outside of the one
with the hell's angels which we'll get
to here in a minute what which one was
you know a couple of them you can say
where this was absolutely crazy that i
faced off over here
here's what i worked on with this i
heard something about you did something
with the rodney king trial you know the
rodney king writes there was a lot of
different things you worked on
but can you share a couple of the
stories with us sure you know the uh
the hells angels case which gets all the
notoriety and attention
is is not my favorite investigation or
my favorite case
it's i'm not even sure it's in the top
five or top ten
to be quite honest with you um
you mentioned waco i responded uh after
the fact
to the events at waco i responded
after the fact to the columbine high
school shooting
um i responded to the rodney king riots
um so that like i i touched some
uh historical events national
nationally historical events during my
career
but you know the reality of this is like
as an undercover operator i bought
everything
from street corner dope up to cartelgo
you know i bought saturday night special
peashooters in the park
up to shoulder launch like anti-aircraft
rockets
everything from homemade pvc pipe bombs
that some tweaker was making in his
garage or his mom's basement
up to servo remote-controlled c4 devices
you know i worked on home invasion
infiltrations and murder for hire cases
and gang infiltrations um
me and my partner uh infiltrated
an element of timothy mcveigh's
the remnants of timothy mcveigh's crew
that was operating in southern nevada
after mcveigh set off his bomb
at the oklahoma city at the at the
murrah federal building in oklahoma city
that were planning oklahoma city part
two
they had intended to blow up three
las vegas casinos the mirage the
treasure island and the golden nugget
me and my partner infiltrated that
scheme
and defused that plan um
another case an undercover program of
mine
infiltrated an element of the aryan
brotherhood and over the course
of 100 days bought
100 improvised explosive devices
that members of the aryan brotherhood
were building
for us so that we that we could use
you know to do murders and
assassinations and intimidations
when i look at those two cases in the in
the context of the hal's angels case
i think they're more important because i
think they um
had a significant a significantly more
important safety element to them
if these guys that were going to blow up
these casinos in las vegas were able to
carry
through that plan it's easy to imagine
you know thousands of people being
injured and killed
um this airing brotherhood case where we
were buying all these
ieds they were selling us
selling those devices to us with the
intention that we were using them
to murder and name people um
those were those are important
investigations that didn't get a lot of
attention that didn't get a lot of
publicity
that that without a crystal ball
to say what would have happened but it's
not hard to speculate that they saved
lives
and saved people from significant
significant injuries
how how do you become a an
undercover and keep the
lack of hate and distaste for them and
and be able to make them believe that
you're one of them and still be able to
you know uh catch them committing a
crime
how do you manage those two
personalities
um i think uh you have to be a
sociopath i i i would have to agree
because
you know when i when i talked to joe
pistone you know donnie barrasco joe
pastone who was undercover for the whole
uh the the mob families the five
families that he brought down
six years for him to be undercover i
mean that's a long time he was married
during that time to be able to be able
to do it
and i asked him a question i said how do
you not
flip like you know people can act
and then even in hollywood you do as
seen as 30 seconds
you you do a monologue maybe like what
edward norton did in american history
exceeds eight minutes that's sick when
somebody does that right
are you talking about acting for a month
two months two years with your case with
uh how do you do that how do you manage
the two personalities of who you are and
who you're acting to be
the honest answer to that is not
a flattering answer it's not a hero
answer
there's elements to this answer that i
am uh ashamed of i'm i'm
regretful of i carry the guilt for
um i i wasn't
very good at separating
my undercover persona from who i was god
um i had played that role
for so long and so aggressively
that now in hindsight regretfully
my job evolved from what i did
to who i was um
and i became addicted to lying
i i became i became addicted to the scam
to the hustle um and every time i was
successful at it
my my ego grew
and so you know i'll tell you a little
story i think that that's a good
demonstration of it
i had spent routinely months and
weeks away from home and i came home one
time
and my wife told me you cannot be gone
for months and walk in the door here and
talk to us talk to me and your kids
like one of your suspects out on the
street
in my self-defense i told her
i am not a light switch i cannot turn
this
off and on people who do what i do for a
living
and treat it as a hobby or dabble in it
or treat it as a gimmick
end up dead i'm not a light switch and
then her response
to that was i understand you're not a
light switch i understand you have to be
on all the time
but when you come to this house you
better install a dimmer switch
and take that attitude down a notch and
if you can't
don't come back wow
she told you that and i had it coming
i had at the time it pissed me off at
the time i was very resistant to it
because i was so
in that role now stepping back from it
um probably my biggest regret uh my my
shame
my guilt from all this is the amount of
battle damage
that i put on my family trying to take
care of other people's problems
you know in reality in hindsight the
people that loved me the most
the people that cared about me the most
my biggest fans my biggest supporters
were the people that i treated the
shittiest
and and that is uh that's a burden
that that i just have to carry
that's that's uh i can only imagine
by the way are you still married are you
guys still together married
i i am you know by the grace of god my
wife
and my kids are so much
better than i ever deserve you're still
married to the same woman as you were
married to when you got into the game
uh 30 plus years now we've been married
you know our kids are grown
and you know i'll tell you um
i've given her i've given my life a
million reasons to throw
everything that belongs to me at this
house out on the front lawn
and say get out and she has given me a
million and one second chances
that's an angel right there whoever you
married if she's watching this man i
salute you
uh uh much respect for for that you know
to uh
to be able to go through that you know
it's it's when when i'm when i'm asking
the question for you and i'm saying you
know
flipping and going which side heath
ledger is getting ready to do
joker he's going to play the role of
joker right and
he goes and asks jack nicholson who
played one of the jokers in the past
and he says hey i'm thinking about
playing joker i'm getting the offer what
do you think
and jack nicholson told him don't do it
that is the one rule i highly recommend
you not doing it because psychologically
it mess with my head
and you got to realize jack nicholson's
done what's the one he did cuckoo's nest
the old old movie you know playing a
little bit off and nursing
a grown man nursing a woman you know
that scene and he says don't do joker
this is coming probably one of the
craziest actors of all time
and heath ledger goes and does it and
probably by the way i even have a statue
of him over here i mean you gotta
this guy goes and does the the joker and
he crushes it
and then he comes out and we know what
happens with heath ledger right
and there's a scene where i think it's
tmz goes to the restaurant that jack
nicholson's about to go into
camera guy stands outside saying hey
jack did you hear about what happened
with heat ledger
he said what happened he said uh they
found him dead
he says what says they found him dead he
says i
told him don't play joker there's a
scene it's a very interesting scene when
you look at this
how dark of a place did you go if you
were to say to the darkest of darkest
places you went to
playing these 500 different events you
know
people you're around the types of people
you're around if you were to say pat i
went to the darkest place these three
places
where the darkest place it was if you
could do your best to paint a picture to
us
what what did that look like well uh
i'll answer it this way i have found
from my experience
that there's two uh types of undercover
operators
there are are operatives that like have
a costume
that fits the role that they play and
they
come to work and they put that costume
on and then they inherit that
personality and they become that person
whatever that whatever that year or
gimmick is
i was never good at that i was just like
what you see
is what you get i i talk to people
on the street the same way i'm talking
to you i i
i interact with people i was not good at
faking being someone
um or at least having a personality
other than my personality
but i will say this um when we look at
the world of good guys and bad guys and
good versus evil and
and whose side are you on i found that
oftentimes the good people are not
always all that good
and the bad people oftentimes are not
always that all that bad
and so then i i have so many like
character flaws and personality traits
that are unflattering
and things that i don't like about
myself
um and some of those i actually learned
to put into play and to highlight
my undercover world uh that there's
there's like i have a dark side to me i
try to project
positivity i try to encourage people um
and promote people but
when i'm putting the right situation
around the corner like i can be the
nicest
best guy in the world i can also be the
dirtiest nastiest [ __ ] out there
um and being able to be those two people
that's i'm not sure that that's healthy
or normal
um but i played on that i
i knew that about me and so i used it to
my advantage
i tried to treat people good i tried to
like communicate with people in a proper
way
but man when you turned on me or when
you got sideways with me or my partners
or you put us in danger or whatever
oh man i was i was the baddest cat on
the planet
give me one example oh my goodness
there's so many to pick from
there was a point during the hell's
angels case where
some of the suspects had gotten some
legitimate information
and our cover was compromised
our cover was uh
it was in risk it was like the truth was
coming out
and the the line was starting to crumble
and i was confronted by some hell's
angels
on that exact thing on that exact
information
like this is what we're here um
and i got so nasty and spun it back on
them
and turned it around on them that they
were full of [ __ ]
that they weren't hearing quite accurate
information they knew me
i had proven myself time and time again
over years and years
and cited events in sighted situations
and got really
uh frustrated and angry about it to the
point that these people came into this
meeting
accusing me and in a position of power
and i flipped that entire situation on
them
to the point where we left they were
apologizing
you're you're july 24th is that what you
are are you july 24th yeah interesting
now let me ask you if i was in high
school with you were you a tough guy
were you somebody i didn't want to screw
with was that still
were those two characters still there if
i was in 10th grade with you
no like and i don't carry myself
like a tough guy like i don't walk down
the street uh
like looking for someone no but but
let's just say if we're buddies if you
and i are boys and i'm your i'm your
right i'm your running mate like we
party together we go to high school
parties
we we go with the girls we play football
let's just say you're the star i'm the
blocker i'm the titan
we're really really tight okay somebody
says something to me and disrespects me
were you ready to brawl or no were you
more like trying to defuse
yeah you know what i um i i didn't
and do not try to carry myself as a
tough guy but
um like like don't put me in a corner
man
and don't you know don't box me in i
will walk away
from a problem if i have opportunity i
will run away from a problem
if i have an opportunity but if you put
me in the corner
like we're gonna get it out and and
like you might hurt me you might hit me
or we're all going to the hospital
um and you were always like that you
were always like that even as a kid
you know my my dad who was a huge
influence in my life
as a young man told me you know what the
nastiest worst most vile
things someone can say about you is
what's the most disgusting name
you can be called and as a child i'm i'm
running through
like like swear words vulgar names right
he said let me tell you what the
nastiest thing
anybody can ever say about you s
o f t soft
never let anybody say you're soft
i wrote this thinking maybe your dad's a
coward but
soft i like that your dad said never let
anybody say you're soft
wow that's pretty that's pretty big how
old were you when he told me that was it
probably you know seven eight years old
now you said your dad was a carpenter
like yeah my dad was a carpenter and he
was
uh like and he you know he kind of lived
that same life he was a very like
peaceful guy he was a sweet man
but man that dude was tough
he was tough and he was not someone that
anybody wanted to tangle with
uh jay craziest thing you've seen
craziest [ __ ] you've seen
ever on work craziest thing you've seen
right like witness right in front of you
not read about but you witnessed
um one of the most disturbing things
for me um like like i do not like dead
bodies man
i'm not i that's it's not my thing
right i would not be a good homicide
detective because i do not like dead
bodies
um we're working a cartel case uh
with some pretty high-level narcotics
trafficking
and one of the people we're dealing with
got sealed up in a 55
gallon steel drum
and left out in the desert and when they
recovered that barrel
and popped the top of it off this
this human being had become
like stew like soup
in that barrel and i was you know
that was like the sight of that the
smell of that
the thought of someone being sealed
alive
in a steel barrel and left in the desert
and
the misery with the suffocation
and the and all the things that i that i
imagined
went into that person's death i was like
man i don't care
i don't care what you're doing or i
don't care who you are man nobody's got
that comment
that's not a way to go sammy the bull
said if i had one way to go i'd want to
get
a shot in the head is that what he said
he said i'd like to get shot in the head
that's the way to go because you don't
feel anything
you do not want to go that way what a
way to go
what a way to go so okay so now you know
the other part i always wonder is uh uh
yesterday i was doing a call with
some of my leaders and these are sales
guys
and in the world of sales there's
prospecting in the world of prospecting
there's getting rejected if you see
you know when i was coming up there was
a buddy of mine that was the best
looking guy in the world
but out of all our friends but the guy
was afraid of getting rejected by girls
and he was nervous what if she says no
what if this what if that and he looked
he looked like chisel he had the perfect
jaw you know those guys that
he just had the look and some of us
weren't afraid of that and some of us
got more play than he did but he was the
best looking of the bunch
when it comes down to prospecting
a lot of people are afraid of uh talking
to somebody that's a non-client or a
girl because of anxiety it creates this
level of anxiety right okay
so most people today there are so many
books being written about anxiety panic
attacks all this other stuff
how do you control your anxiety and your
panic when you're wired you know if they
take your jacket off or your shirt off
you may be wire tap you may have stuff
that they're going to see you can turn
bad you can get killed your life's on
the line
you're thinking about your wife and two
kids you're thinking about the stories
over with
how do you stay poised because there's
many ways for people to
tell if you're nervous if you're lying
there's many different ways
how do you keep yourself calm well you
know the fear of failure
is a huge motivator and and how do we
react to that how do we handle that
um you talked about your friendship with
kobe
um and and there's uh
thousands of stories about kobe speaking
on
the motivating element of the fear of
failure
uh we saw it over and over in the last
dance documentary with jordan how
like he like actually invented things to
be fearful of to motivate him
um like i have a formula
right and i think this formula applies
to me i think it applies to you i
believe it applies
to uh sports teams businesses
families it is the key for all of us to
success how do we overcome that anxiety
how do we
we're nervous about something we have an
objective we have you're trying to close
a deal
you're trying to accomplish something
that's super important to you
establish the purpose be clear on what
your purpose is
be clear on what your objective is
have open and honest dialogue have
transparent dialogue with the people
around you
because when you are open and honest and
when you speak transparently with people
you build trust you build two-way trust
the people that you're speaking to the
people that you've surrounded with
yourself with
hopefully because you're being open and
honest
will that will develop a trust in you
and then that open communication
you will build trust in them so you get
this two-way trust so now you've got
your purpose
established you've like you've
got open and honest communication and
you've built trust
when you have those three things
together
you can go solve problems and that is
what
any high achiever in the world does
and it doesn't matter if you're flying
the space shuttle
or if you're pushing a room as a janitor
it doesn't matter if you're in sales or
whatever it is that you're doing if
you're in law enforcement
if you're on a sports team the people
that are great
and the units that are great solve
problems
think about it just think about you on a
daily basis
the number of problems and conflicts
that you have to resolve
people who are great at it ultimately
are
our our highest achievers
so how do we solve problems through
having a purpose having open
communication with the people around us
and building trust
together when we have that together
that's how we went down the moon
that's how any great thing in the world
has ever been accomplished
establishing a purpose having open
communication with the people around us
building trust and then together going
to solve that problem
that was that was my my professional
life in law enforcement in a nutshell
none of us ever accomplished anything
alone none of us ever
get great achievements all by ourselves
there's always people around us that
help us and encourage us and give us new
ideas and better ideas
yeah but in those moments like when i
think about you
and i think about uh uh when you're
when you're in that moment and you're
getting a call and saying hey jay
get all your guns and come meet us at
this place
why are we going to go kill somebody
don't ask questions just show up
this is the first year when you're a
prospect and you're kind of going
through it right
and like [ __ ] what do we do and your
partner at the time
was sue pops right so you and him he's
also another atf agent
both of you guys are undercover you're
getting a call like that
i understand you're saying purpose i
understand you're saying open dialogue
and communication i understand building
trust
but you're in hell's angels
their purpose is narcotics
killing crime money women anything to
break the law
you know open dialogue communication
what open communication
and then what trust do you have with
them how are you maintaining your
anxiety in those heated moments when it
all of a sudden comes up because
there's a big difference between there's
a big difference even with that when
you're getting a call and saying grab
your guns and come by okay you can call
the atf and talk to them say guys i just
got this call what the hell do i do
and then they can coach you through it
well you know jay here's what i suggest
you do
you and pops jump on a quick conference
call together and you're getting a
briefing fine
but what if you're in the moment and
you're on the bike
and you're going and they said this
bastard said this we got to go and do
this and
jay you know here's some cocaine in here
let's do this and
you're taking 20 hydroxycuts a day and
six red bulls a day and you're trying to
hold it together
how are you staying calm in that moment
in that moment i think that
when we look at anything from the
outside
with without familiarity with it
like like things appear to us to be
overwhelmed
so like for me i look at like some guy
who can fly the space shuttle
i'm like how does he process all that
some guy that's going to operate on
somebody's brain
how do you have the confidence to take a
knife
and open up somebody's head and get in
there and move things around
but they're great at what they do
and and what they do becomes routine
through training repetition
experience exercise all those things
right and so when when you
look at them and they're saying like man
i can never do that people look at what
i did
and say i can never do that i'm like uh
you know what
yes you could if you had the experience
and the training
um and all these things that built up
that i had built up over years
it those things create confidence
and with confidence comes comfort so
you're asking like how did i how did i
contain this anxiety from these
situations that were spinning out of
control
that were in some cases life-and-death
situations
and what you say or what you did
or how you acted or responded could be
the factor on whether you lived or died
right i had become
so comfortable in my role and so
confident in my role that
like i felt like i could get through
anything man i was bulletproof
i had a bullet go through my chest 15
years before that
i was bulletproof i had been through
all these situations before like i had
brainwashed myself
into believing that i was the baddest
cat on the streets but i was the
smartest cat on the streets
and so the question is in this comfort
confidence equation what comes first
what comes second
are we naturally confident and then that
allows us to
operate comfortably or um
do we in the undercover world do we
build build a persona for ourselves that
we're comfortable with and then it
allows us to project confidence
i've never been able to figure out which
one comes first or second but i know
this
that the people i was dealing with
the more time i spent with them i would
start to build
trust then i would build loyalty
i would build their belief there was a
point in time
where some of the most violent
intimidating men on the planet i have no
god in my mind
would have stepped in front of a bullet
for jaybird davis
wow because i had i had taken that
that loyalty and that trust and that
confidence
and given them comfort and it had
evolved into love in some cases
now those same people when they found
out
that jaybird davis the gun-running debt
collecting hitman
was actually a federal agent named jay
dobbins those same people
were looking to put a baseball bat on
the back of my head or drag a straight
razor across my throat
so it can change quickly especially in
that world
yeah a couple things by the way did you
ever feel like those guys got so close
to you
where you started liking them and then
you felt like you betrayed them did you
ever feel like that or not at all
i felt like that all the time throughout
the course of my career
i would extend pieces of myself to these
people and i would let them into my
world
and i spent time with people who were
sometimes uh involved in some very
vicious wicked vile activities
and you see that element of them and
it's so disappointing in humanity
right but then when you spend an
extended amount of time with people like
in an undercover environment
you also see other elements of their
life and you see
redeeming qualities of their character
so that when you see him do something
wicked it's like man
you're so much better than this and i'll
give you an example i i befriended a
couple guys in the hell's angels
hung out with them enjoyed spending time
with them they were smart
they were they were handsome uh they had
professional careers one was a stock
broker
one was involved in the investment world
or in the financial world um
these are smart guys man these are not
uh
these are are not like the stereotypical
guys right
um rode motorcycles with them went to
parties with them drank with them shot
pool with them they stayed at my house i
stayed at their house i saw them around
kids i saw them around women other
people
and actually developed an affection for
these guys like i kind of like these
guys right
one night they took a woman
at the mesa clubhouse a woman named
cynthia garcia a mother of six
she insulted them in the mesa clubhouse
they boot-stopped her to the brink of
death they thought she was dead
they rolled her up in a piece of cut up
carpeting
put her in the trunk of a car drove her
out
to the desert east of phoenix in apache
junction
and stabbed her 27 times and cut her
head off
so like like trying to balance that
trying to balance
like interacting with these people
having them sleep at your house
you're asleep and they're asleep in the
same house socializing with
uh like like being socially interactive
with them
and then knowing that they have
that capability that they have such
low uh for lack of better terms
respect or admiration for for humanity
for another human being that they could
take a defenseless woman
who had i mean the mother of six and
take her in the desert
and saw her head off with a butt knife
that's that's i don't even know what to
say about that
yeah that's that's dirty at the highest
level i mean
psychologically to know that somebody
can get to that level i know the mob
family will always use the word capable
meaning he's capable
he's capable meaning he can kill
somebody if you cross the line
he's willing to kill somebody but
there's a different level to capability
you know based on this topic going back
to some something you said where you
said
i was invincible i got shot i almost
died you know
so for me i felt untouchable i
brainwashed myself into thinking i'm
you know uh toughest guy in the streets
there's a book called
david and goliath where the author talks
about the fact that
uh not david versus goliath as david
engele
the author talks about three different
types of people
who have close encounters with death
whether it was bombing or something it
was one person that missed it it's one
person that
should have died but didn't die the
story was those who
should have died but don't die
can come out pushing the envelope so
much more than they did before
because they have this feeling of i'm
untouchable i'm i'm immort you can't
kill me
you know there's you can't do nothing to
me did you
almost have that because some people
come out after they get shot and have a
close encounter
they become more pansies they become
scared they're kind of like oh my gosh
what if this happens and then there's
some that come obviously you came out
like this
so the story you're talking about the
fact that that event made you even
tougher thinking you were untouchable
did you actually believe that
you know along the lines of of that book
and that explanation that analogy
um to be quite honest with you at that
point in time in my life
i had i had written off my own death
i i had accepted my own death i didn't
know uh
how it was going to come or by whose
hand or what the circumstance might be
but and this is not flattering to say
i was so all in i was so committed to
what i was doing
that i knew that something tragic
was beyond the reality could be it had
become a probability
and so but but when you can accept that
and balance that
i think it allowed me to operate even
more aggressively
if that makes any sense of course
because i accepted my mortality and i
realized that there was a probability
that something bad or tragic was going
to happen during this window over time
and when you accept it it's like man
you know like it actually it's not a
good place to be
because as an undercover operator it
makes you dangerous
and you become dangerous because you
start ignoring
signs you start ignoring red planets you
these things that you know and are
trained
to be triggers for you to heighten your
sense of awareness and to pay closer
attention
you start ignoring and then you start
saying man but i'm jaybird
and all none of that applies to me
that's crazy the level of recklessness
but by the way if you read strong
generals of all time these strong
generals got to the point that you just
said right now
they have to get to a point where they
accepted that like that that is a
possibility that is an option i could go
in there
and die and if you don't accept that
you're you're going to be a little bit
timid as well so the opposite of that
in your world of timidity you know
you're you're too timid you can't really
go
to places that you need to push the
envelope by the way you said i was fully
all in
and i was fully into my my craft were
you saying were you all into atf
all into jay or all into whatever camp
you were a part of
um probably all the above i i believed
i believed in the mission that i was
serving i believed in our battle against
violent crime i
i wholeheartedly um
i believe in the in the objectives of
our operation
of our mission as to what we are trying
to accomplish but
probably with more as more and more time
uh passed and as i got deeper and deeper
into that role
it became more and more focused on me
and i think that my um regretfully
uh to be quite honest with you um i
started making
selfish decisions instead of practical
operational mission-driven decisions
um the mission was to
uh uncover violent crime find out who
was
um committing it who was ordering it who
was organizing it who was benefiting
from it
um as i got deeper and deeper in that
role
my selfishness started narrowing
those those decisions and that focus and
i started making decisions for me
i started making decisions like how am i
going to advance
in this organization how am i personally
going to achieve um and
like that that element of that team
player element started to fade away
and my selfishness started
starting becoming more dominant and
that's and that's that's
that's just not good that's not good you
know who was the chief disguise officer
we sat down with in dc right outside the
white house
john a mendez yeah so we sat down with
john mendes her husband
is uh the gentleman from argo
who played i mean you know the story and
so i asked her i said
john let me ask you this what makes for
a good cia agent right
undercover she gave me the craziest
answer jay
like literally i remember till today she
said someone like you
okay someone who is charming charismatic
can sell
can convince the other person that
they're on their camp
but when he takes down russia he never
brags about it
do you remember that and she says most
guys cannot do that because it's so hard
you just took
down and you know the kremlin what do
you mean you don't want to brag about it
you want to tell a couple of your
friends at a bar and say dude
if you want a super bowl what do you say
we just beat the patriots we just beat
whatever
he says in this world you can't brag
about it to nobody my
my friends my peers uh the
the world of undercover operatives
who've done like
long-term deep cover infiltrations yeah
it's it's a
it's a fairly small fraternity right
and something i've noticed about that's
common
amongst all these guys is that they're
very humble
they're very gracious they're very quick
to brag on the success and the exploits
and the achievements of their friends
and their peers
but on any given opportunity
on any given day they feel that they
are the best and that no one else should
take that case
i've interviewed a lot of those guys and
i've been in some for whatever random
reasons i've had a chance to spend a lot
of time with them
and very common true very common they're
very similar when
you when you talk to them and by the way
they play a very important role it's not
a job everybody wants to do what you're
doing
hats off to you you know because not a
lot of people wake up in the morning
saying i want to have jay's life
uh jay similarities of what you saw with
rodney king back in the days i had just
come to the states
i came to the states from iran i was at
a refugee camp in germany came out here
november 28 1990
and then rodney king i think happened in
92 and i was in la for
you know at the time what similarities
do you see with what happened with
rodney king
versus george floyd and black lives
matter what we have going on today with
protesting and riots
man that's such it's a great question
it's a question that
a lot of people um want a lot of people
want to avoid
i think it's a question that a lot of
white people want to avoid
uh people in law enforcement to like
sometimes want to avoid it
um what i think is is the
the common denominator is that there has
been
such a breakdown in trust
in law enforcement there's there's
there's no trust there like there's
there's multiple reasons
for uh why
that has taken place over the course of
time
but the public
no longer trusts the police
to protect them whether that be real or
whether that be
uh uh false or imagined or fabricated
it doesn't matter the trust is wrong
so i i i truly
think that um i i really
think on the on the massive picture of
this
that god is looking at us and weeping
i think god is crying right now um
that that that we that we're all better
than this
you know and you look at trust and you
look at race relations and all these
things
you know if you go to the to the
declaration of independence
which which gives us
the life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
and all men being created equal all men
all men being created equal um
i think god is is looking at us and he
is weeping
that we have failed
to be able to live up to that
it's a tough topic you know but it kind
of goes back to what you said earlier
which is
uh the way you're able to do your work
and keep anxiety done
step number one was what purpose number
two was communication
and the last one is build trust and
we're missing all those three we're not
talking about purpose we're definitely
not communicating and there's no trust
so
uh i i you know i my opinion is all of
this stuff got started a lot of it got
started and got reignited because
roger goodell didn't have the audacity
to meet with kaepernick right after he
kneeled the first time i wonder what
would have happened if kaepernick would
have
just gotten a call from godel and said
hey we want to fly you out to the
headquarters and sit down and talk to
plus nfl pa and
let's address this what can we do to
support this imagine what would have
happened
if that issue was addressed immediately
rather than waiting three six twelve
months and it turned into what it is
today so
well i'll give you just one one
perspective on that just one man's
perspective
i think that it is important for us all
of us
uh be open and willing
to change your mind i i think many of us
do not want to change our mind we do not
want to change our viewpoint and we hear
a compelling arguments on either side
that should convince us to be
open-minded
um but like oftentimes our stubbornness
doesn't want to let us change it it is
okay to change your mind
it is okay to say the way i felt about
something
five years ago or five days ago is
different than how i feel about it today
it's okay
it's very hard to do i know what you're
saying believe me i know what you're
saying but it's
very very hard to do especially when you
have all these people that have been
ingrained in a way of thinking by their
parents and
media and teachers and professors and
churches and
organizations they're part of in
communities they lived in it's like
betraying
your heritage it's a very tough thing to
do
and i think one of the reasons why it's
tough to do is because most people are
not willing to reason if you cannot
reason
kiss a goodbye there's not much we can
do about it you get it on the head
and i think it's we've become all or
none
so if you are committed to the
to the black lives matter movement or if
you're committed to the blue lives
matter movement
right and and that is what you believe
in
talk about and i'm sympathetic to your
to your cause to your agenda i want to
support you
i want to be in in many people's case
supportive of both those
both those things there's people in
those camps
that out of the 100 issues i might agree
with you
on 99 of those issues but if i don't
agree with you on that 100th if i don't
agree with you on
100 out of 100 i become the enemy
like i agree with 99 of the of the
things you believe in there's one that
i'm stuck on
hey if you're not all in with me if you
don't agree with me across the board
line item
you're the enemy and man how do we like
how do we ever improve
or how do we ever get better if
if if that's where we're at
it's a very very good point it's a very
very good point
but you know the adversary and the and
the media
if he talk if they talk about 99 things
we agree and who watches
they have to talk about the one thing we
disagree and because those get eyeballs
and if those get eyeballs then all the
other people are willing to pay the
money to
get the eyeballs because when they're
showing the nielsen records of how many
people watch our show
that's what they get a million dollar
contract versus a 200 000 contract
so advertising dollars tend to speak
let's talk lastly about the
health angels which is what you were
part of for a couple years
uh what was it like just give us an idea
what it was like when you got in and you
know the experience of going through it
i'll tell you what it wasn't like it
wasn't like the stereotype
that um that america holds
of bikers these guys were not
uh like this pack of
greasy slimy dirty motorhead
drug addicts were there people within
that world that fit that stereotype of
course
but um they were
smart they were especially street smart
they conducted themselves
socially a lot of times
fairly pleasantly i didn't find
that i was riding around with guys who
were just like
getting on a motorcycle to go out at
night looking for someone to
have their head caved in they were
focused
they were organized
now they weren't necessarily
um all of them book smart like educated
college-educated booksmart
but they have their phds in the street
they have their phds and violence and
intimidation
and the motivating
factor in it was hate and was money
for what though what did they hate they
hated uh
their adversaries they hated people that
were trying to uh
that either insulted them that were
disrespectful of them
that wanted to infringe on their
territory which
the infringement on territory then comes
back
to money is because that's that's where
money's made that's where money's made
in
in crime in in narcotics distribution
and prostitution and all those things
the the territory you you control
and you own expands or or
retracts your your your area of
operations
um so what was your time when you were
there what years were you undercover
2001 through 2003. oh oh so you were at
that laughlin event
so you you were you at the laughlin
event i was
uh april 27 02. yes
yes i was uh i was at uh
a party with the hell's angels when the
call came in
and they all left the party that i was
at
and went to the harrah's casino and got
into
the big brawl and the shootout that was
all captured on the casino cameras and
um yeah and i mean that looks brutal
what happened over there looks
absolutely brutal what took place
that's the big event they talk about i
think that's a
it was a demonstration of the brazenness
and i think it was a demonstration
of the commitment and the brotherhood
and the loyalty that
um they could rally up together that
quickly they could
uh move their location that quickly and
then
when they arrived on scene they did not
care
everybody knows uh gambling casino
has got 10 000 cameras around
watching everything they didn't care um
and i thought a very interesting element
is that when the
when the battle settled there were
mongol vests
screwing around where they had stripped
off their colors trying to escape
stuffed in air vents stuffed in garbage
cans some were seen floating down the
river
there was a casino was on the colorado
um not one house angel vest was
recovered
those guys were not did not
would not take off their colors they
were so
committed to that patch to that death
head
to that name they they they were gonna
uh they were gonna win that fight or die
trying but they were not gonna take
those cuts off
so you're saying uh the the hells
dangers were more proud and brutal than
mongols were is that what you're saying
i i don't know if i use those terms but
i'll say this
um the prospecting process the phases
for a house angel are extensive and
they're long
like a minimum mandatory 365 days
prospecting
as a hells angel before you can even be
considered to get
your cut um
yeah i saw that other gangs
like there was times got it where the
mongols
were actually approaching street gang
members saying hey
here's a mango's vest learn how to ride
a motorcycle
if you have to work for something if you
have to suffer for something if you have
to sacrifice for something
it's more important to you that is why
organizations
um not just in biker land
uh sports teams all muslims you suffer
and sacrifice and spend time so that
when you get it it's me
it has me and those angels they
know that what they went through to get
that cut
and they were uh not going to give it up
whereas if someone from another biker
gang if it just got handed to you
what meaning does that truly have what
value is that shooting at
that makes sense so standards and
expectations were higher
maybe that's a way of putting it you
know uh to to get in
and become a made man essentially for
uh a angels uh hell's angels was higher
than it was to become a mongol well then
when you're a member of the hell's
angels you are at the you are at the top
of the biker mountain you are the king
of the mountain
um any any housewife any mechanic
any school teacher police officer if you
say biker
automatically what comes into their mind
is the hell's engines
and when you were at the top when you're
at the top of the mountain
everybody underneath you wants to knock
you out
everybody wants that position and so
their adversaries are everybody
everybody wants to be them
and so what does that do that creates
paranoia
in them everybody's after us everybody
hates us everybody wants to be us
um and that's that's that's a bad
uh formula man that's bad chemistry
bad chemistry why because you think
internally people are dividing you and
maybe somebody on the inside is going to
go and
tip off what we're doing strategies is
that what it is you're paranoid you're
worried about maintaining your status
you know that uh that everybody wants to
be the king of the mountain you know
what if you're the um
if you're the heavyweight champion of
the world you don't get to just say
i'm the new heavyweight champion in the
world you got to knock that cat out to
take the belt
and they know that everybody wants to
come and knock them out right
that is right so just to put some optics
out there some numbers out there
hells angels 2500 members uh uh
mongols 500 hells angels had 230
different chapters mongols had like 12
different chapters
hells angels the founder was sunny is it
sunny berger sunny
sunny barger is a founder and then and
then you have on the other side with uh
uh mongols was uh what's his name uh
penny penny uh
roger penny am i saying it right he was
a member he was a shot caller
he was a shot caller at the time so when
these guys were facing off each other
and you are kind of going in with your
um
partner pops and he's also an atf by the
way he
he does not look like an atf agent like
he is a qualified
i couldn't even tell like he looked like
a guy that was
partying all the time using drugs and
women
he pla he's either an incredible actor
or he got really deep into it
well let me qualify that just a little
bit pops was a confidential informant
he was not atf so there's he
he was in essence working with us for us
um but he was not a badge carrying
agent he was a confidential informer so
how long had he been himself with the
hell's angels well he'd been with them
uh
the same time i was with them i brought
him with me
but like he hit it on the head there's
no
faking pops likes experiences that
brought him to that point in time
you cannot uh you cannot train through
that you can't fake that
you had to have lived that life to look
and act like that did you trust him
i did i did i trusted pops i had built
uh you know loyalty with him well before
we work the hells angels case
i've worked on many operations with them
and i did trust them
and um because i wonder sometimes i'm
like could you even trust him you know
like if he's your partner can you fully
trust him because
maybe he can be bought with you know
money
women drugs i mean what's his motive he
made you know he made some mistakes
along the way he got a little bit loose
at times he needed to be tightened up
you know and jerk his leash
keep him online but did i trust him to
answer that question
as simply as it was asked do i trust him
yes i did
that's good that's interesting yeah that
dynamic is you always wonder
especially now that you're telling me he
was an atf he was just somebody as an
informant that was helping out
how how far did you have to go to show
loyalty you know how far did you have to
go to show loyalty
meaning hey did you drugs
women crime killing shooting how
how far did you go when they said damn
this guy is actually legit
well i can answer that with one story
when i first came into the hells angels
i approached the leadership
and said what are the rules like like
what like
what what do you expect of me i'd want
to be a good hell's angel i'm
you know i've been trained um and the
leader of my
uh charter said it's your job to kill
models
that's what we do so for in essence two
years i took that information and put it
in my back pocket
right and held on to that that mindset
that mantra
as the case was beginning to end um
i told the hell's angels there's a
mongol in mexico
and he's uh threatening us and
threatening to like import narcotics
into our area
and i need to go down there and kill him
that's that's what i'm going to do
i'm going to go kill him on behalf of
the band the people i spoke to
were 100 behind him gave me the gun to
do it told me how to do it
all these things right so go to mexico
kill this model bury them in a you know
shallow grave take some pictures of them
all bloodied up
and shot up and beat bring them back to
the hell's angels tell them
tell the house angels the story of how
we had killed the mongol in mexico and
and gave them hard cold evidence of the
murder
that is ultimately what got us over the
top where they gave us
pests and made us members what they
didn't know
and what we didn't tell them is that an
entire scheme was a fabrication
i had told the mom of the angels about
this bond with mexico and then
with the use of our team and a homicide
detective
we went out in the desert outside of
phoenix
and completely fabricated a murder scene
and then took the evidence that we had
created from our homemade
murderer put it in a fedex box
had it shipped to my undercover house
from mexico so that it would look right
be credible um all those things
presented the information to the hell's
angels and
you know one of the elements that's key
to undercover work is
inaccurate conclusions from accurate
observations
they accurately heard my story they
accurately saw the bloody mongol vessel
they saw the pictures of the model in
the
in the shallow grave in the desert with
his hands and his feet duct taped
and his brain spilled out in the dirt
they accurately saw
that they inaccurately concluded that i
was telling them the truth and had
committed a murder
and so when you say how far when your
question how far did we have to go
to gain acceptance we went to the
acceptance where we
built a homicide and then sold the fact
that we were murderers two murderers in
order to get inside the game
is it true that you use the cow's
stomach to make it seem like the brain
was shot up
there were cow parts we went to a
butcher our homicide detective went
through a butcher we had a pound blood
we got cow carts
like i said earlier like i'm not a big
fan of dead bodies
but when i looked at this crime scene i
was like oh my god that thing's dead
like i there was no doubt in my mind
this dude's dead
you know when i talked to philly and
eddie or i talked to sammy or i talked
to michael or frank collado or any of
these guys that were in the mob world
i asked him how much was uh the because
you know
in the mob side it's more about the
lifestyle
you know you have money you're rich
you're partying
coats you know all this stuff and then
there's the code you live by
but there's women there's partying
there's that other attractive part to it
as well new york
was there hardcore partying going on as
well or you were saying no girls with
three missing tooth and all that stuff
well were you guys partying with woman
non-stop
there was both there were guys that like
you know
were professionals and partied like
no one else right there was also guys
that i ran around with
who went to the gym three times a day
and uh didn't drink didn't smoke didn't
use drugs
meal prepped set their alarms for three
o'clock in the morning so they could get
up and eat a chicken breast because they
needed an infusion of protein
and there was everything in between
which uh
which was good and made it interesting
and it also made it
you didn't have to fit into one box to
be accepted
because there were so many different
types of people so you don't have a
crazy crazy party story uh with them
oh man i mean there's parties you know
like cocaine
bashes and nitrous oxide parties and
and and girls running around and music
glaring and
booze flowing and fights and and
people [ __ ] in the corner and and all
that kind of stuff
that's that was normal i was a normal
life for that
you know what i don't know that i would
say it was normal but it wasn't abnormal
okay yeah that makes sense so for
somebody that's watching this you you
keep hearing about ms-13
we some people that know biker they know
hell's angels they know mongols banditos
obviously we know some of the names
right
you hear about all these other gangs
that are out there
which one how vicious were they
comparable to an ms-13
i think that uh the hell's angels if you
do not cross
them if you do not cross their business
if you do not cross their territory
you may very well never notice that
they're there
um whereas you know
the ms-13 which like to use your example
and you probably of all people can can
relate to this best
when you grow up in a culture and in a
society
where human beings and humanity
is viewed differently than it is in
america
the things that take place that are
shocking to us
as americans for some people are
everyday common events
so if you grew up in san salvador and
you see
people being beheaded or being hacked up
with machetes
or being tortured publicly and bodies
scattered
in the street and that is what you grew
up with
that is what you grew up with and that's
not abnormal to you
then you come here and you act like that
and we
are appalled and shocked and you're just
acting what's
like what you know
that makes a lot of sense because you
know sometimes
even when i tell some stories from iran
people are like yeah whatever he's
probably making it up i'm like no
and then you go talk to six other
iranians they're like yeah that's what
happened like no way yeah
that was a life interest that's kind of
how i was in iran no way in the world
yeah well i guess i have to believe it
now because i'm hearing it from six
different people that are not connected
to each other
probably what you saw as a child what
what some of these people see in in some
of these countries
as children um
is is so far outside
our american north american realm of
possibility
that what to us is appalling
to other people to actually children in
the world
is commonplace
yeah i i uh i totally agree i totally
agree when i'm sometimes
i bought my first truck from mms 13
leader in la
and the story is a funny story because
my dad's like i found this artist
that i want to show you he wants to sell
you the truck and i said
great i'd love to be able to tell my
friends in school i bought a car from an
artist
so i go to upland which is where the
mechanic shop was and i go to upland and
says yeah you know it's that guy let me
treat this a really nice guy it's good
to me
and i go there everything ms-13
everything and he's got this nice uh
chevy s10 long bed
dropped 144 spokes low profile 14 inch
wheels
system subwoof the whole nine and he
says
here's my friend you know he's an artist
and i'm like
and he's part of a very special
community this community is called ms-13
i'm like
dad ms-13 is one of the most vic you
know
vicious gangs out there no he's very
nice to me anyways i end up buying the
car
first weekend i'm in hollywood partying
i'm 16 years old about to be 16 years
old at that time i
uh i got my license a little bit earlier
i'm at hollywood partying
and cops helicopter above us it's me and
three of my friends were in the truck
cops from behind me cops in front of me
helicopter comes they drop get out of
the car
get up we all get out the car they
thought i was him
and i had bought the car from him and so
because it hadn't yet been registered
under
my name because it was uh just a week we
got arrested that night and then once
they found out i'm not a gangster they
let us go and they said oh
wrong person we got but that was my
experience with ms-13 it's a very
uh um interesting gang uh in la
and uh rumor has it they can go places
that others are not willing to go
through i mean not just rumors you hear
about the stories that you read about
how bad of a time is it right now jay to
be a gangster
how bad of a time is it right now to be
a criminal today's marketplace somebody
is looking at the saying you know what
i'm considering being a
criminal one day how bad of a time is it
today to be a criminal and a street gang
i think as we speak today at this very
moment whatever what is it june
24th 25th um
it's probably really good because the
cops are so distracted
uh the cops are for lack of better terms
handcuffed police departments are being
defunded
um if if i was
a narcotics trafficker i would be
uh pushing as much dope as i can push
right now because i'd be like hey man
that enemy law enforcement
is distracted right now their resources
are divided their resources are being
diminished
now is my window i was
totally expecting you to say the
complete opposite answer
and the way you broke it down makes so
much sense
makes so much sense the reason why i
thought you were going to go to the area
of
it's a terrible time to be a criminal
right now because there's phones
everywhere social media
cameras you got 330 million cameras
pretty much that everybody can catch you
doing the wrong thing
but no you're saying the people who are
criminals number one enemy which is
law enforcement they're crippled right
now this is a great time to be a
criminal
i think i think some of these social
experiments that are taking place in
some of these communities without cops
um and with men where and where cops are
not welcome or not wanted or being
defunded
um i fear that
those communities are going to find out
the hard way
um how important law enforcement is
but more importantly how good how
important good law enforcement is
not just law enforcement like um
like the the the cops the people in the
coptic
we have to up our game we have to be
better we have to improve like in all
areas
are you optimistic are you optimistic
with uh what's going to happen here soon
are you
a little bit paranoid and concerned i'm
optimistic
um in the in the long haul
um that i i think what's taking place
right now
is important and i think that this is
going to be in hindsight a great
time in our country because i think
so much awareness is being brought like
even if we don't agree with how that
awareness is coming about
if we don't agree with some of the
tactics the awareness is nonetheless
being brought it's being forced into our
face
um i think we have to improve and we
have to get better to move forward as a
society
and culture i think down the road on the
long term
we will be better i think on the short
term i think things will get worse
before they get better on the short term
when you say worse what do you mean
worse than riots and protesting
i just think that um
i i think that the uh the militancy
in all these groups um is is not going
to be satisfied
until they get every single thing that
they demand
and um we're still we're still ways away
on a lot of those issues a long ways
away on some of those issues
um a very long ways away on some of
those issues
and um the the various factions and
people on
in every with every agenda you can
imagine out there
are empowered to fight right now um
and maybe they should be maybe
maybe this was maybe what we're going
through uh
uh is is necessary to create the change
we need
to be become who we should be am i
misreading you if i feel like you're
walking on excels right now wanting to
say what you're really thinking about or
no
um i don't think i don't feel like i'm
walking on ratios but i do
think that right now like words
are have never been more important
words have never been more important
because
um what we say and how we say it
is is scrutinized and it's critiqued
and it's manipulated and twisted at
times and so
when i'm when i'm calculated and when
i'm trying to answer
i just realize how important words are
um and important to who's hearing them
yeah what what makes me because i'm
constantly talking about different uh
you know in our company we're 50 50 50
left 50 right you know and
you know whatever let's just say we're
45 45 we got 10 independent or people
that could care let's had a call this
morning with one of our guys at 7 30.
i said politically which way do you lean
he says honestly i have no idea what i
am i said it's actually not a bad place
to be if you don't know who you are
you're probably enjoying life more than
some people who
have taken a position but i've never
seen more powerful people
be careful with the words they're
choosing today
i've never ever seen more powerful
influential people who are worried about
what they're going to say next
because of the consequences they may
face from a community that may come back
saying that was offensive
that could hurt them in their lives
business financially in any possible way
and i'm seeing that across the board i
think someone like yourself
who's hosting the show i think someone
like myself who's a guest
um we we want to say
how we feel and we want to like be
articulate and accurate about it
but we also want to be sensitive to
other people's views not everybody
thinks or feels the same way i do i want
to be respectful of them
and i have to be careful about what i
say
and how i say it i own what i
say and it's not like i'm incapable of
making a mistake
or miss speaking on something but like
you look at all these
factions out there do black lives matter
yes
i believe they do and i support what
they are trying to accomplish
do blue lives matter yes i do i
support like rebuilding the trust and
rebuilding training and making that more
professional um
but like there's some people that don't
want that that won't allow you
to like support both sides you have to
pick one or the other
and and it's it's a it's a again it's a
um i i just keep hearing them and i just
keep hearing and i wonder like what is
needed because
uh uh one way of
pushing the agenda is when the
opposition
just decides to stay quiet not say
anything because they don't want to piss
the wrong person off
and that's exactly where they want you
to be at for you to be frightened of
saying what you really need to say for
other people to say [ __ ] i agree with
them
you know but again weird times we're
living in
uh we're gonna do our part and we're
gonna bring guests on to talk on topics
that are gonna be
getting people to think and you
definitely made me think today from
sitting down with you
jay i salute you for the life you lived
and the service you brought
uh god knows how many thousands of lives
you've saved that we can't count on you
know one day when you go upstairs i'm
sure
you're going to have to talk to him
about some of the parties you did or
some of the people you hung out with and
things you did but i'm sure he's also
going to tell you listen you save
thousands of lives
on what you do with your job i salute
you from me to you thank you for your
service
and the folks if you're watching this
we're going to put a link to
his book below no angel if you haven't
purchased it i highly recommend you get
a new york time bestseller we'll put the
link below
and jay once again thank you so much for
coming out and being a guest somebody
team and i really appreciate it
thank you very much it was a lot of fun
so we've done a lot of bob interviews
we've never done anything that has to do
with hell's angels and this was a
complete different angle talking to jay
dobbins who's the right guy to talk
about this topic so i have two other
interviews i want you to watch
one of them is with the chief disguise
officer jonah mendes which is
who i talked about in the interview
she's the one that put a whole mask
on and when by president bush senior and
president bush couldn't recognize her
because they were deciding to take cia
to a whole different place it's a
brilliant interview if you not watch
and the other one is with a f an fbi
agent that i interviewed
michael mcgowan who did some things
having to do with el chapo
very very different story and it's
possibly being picked up
by sly if you haven't heard his story
click on that to watch it and if you've
not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye